so you if you're at a fancy restaurant
you don't get a meat and cheese plate I
don't carry meat and cheese yeah this is
he's a charcuterie guys I'm recording
what is that I can't do it that that you
know breathe tapas in [ __ ] I don't like
tapas you know what it is [ __ ]
we're like what you know like sure
you've got damn right I don't and then
okay you know what [ __ ] you're not Bob
hey [ __ ] you're that communal do you
use your mind and people pick off your
plate are you kidding me oh hey I'll be
on a date and it's like I get me I'm
[ __ ] mad you got me going he's my
favorite movie dessert what would you
care for dessert do anything I'm not
hungry I'm gonna do the German chocolate
cake yeah with the vanilla ice cream
that sounds good I'll have some of yours
what you won't have some yeah are you
[ __ ] kidding me
you know we'll have some a vine because
the amount of people that my order is
for is one bring in one and a little
extra right bring in one person
you know what else I do if I go out with
if I if I pay for dinner yeah and then
this is my thing and I've talked about
this before but I play for dinner yes
and then someone goes yeah I'll take
this to go
right I'll be like no you're not oh yeah
that's mine Yeah right are you taking a
go no I'm leaving in here throw it away
any time someone's going to pick up the
check yeah I tack on a few things to go
oh you got this that would be amazing
video that's just the power trippy thing
you do no it's not I paid for it so no
let me just do this if they go hey
Bobbie I know you pay for it but can I
take this portion of chicken to go yeah
I'd be like you know what you asked go
ahead but they assume yeah so they go
we'll take the beans and this to go and
I'm like no and how many times by the
way do you wake up the next day and that
to-go order is in the back of your car
I know right that's where I'm sorry they
leave me talking he's taken things to go
and left it in the car before oh yeah
one time I made cookies for the homeless
man under the underpass here I made
oatmeal cookies and he refused he
refused to have me give it to the guy he
would not let me but you just inviting a
stalker
I know psychosis I think he's looking
out for you hot chick out of nowheres
giving me cookies maybe there's a chance
maybe she's the one maybe she's the one
she totally safe Australia night light a
night light with a book and he has it's
really creepy I just wanted to give him
cookies oh he reads yeah
he has a look does he have a look he
looks like he was homeless if he reads
he's perfectly able to fill out a job
application in Australia which by the
way is where they sent all the criminals
to begin with so you are playing with
fire sister and he had a little pillow
with a letter K and that's what got me
do homeless people want food if I was
homeless would I want somebody here's up
my pizza yeah I'd be like [ __ ] you what
if you didn't eat I want crack or
whatever way you're right I just crossed
the line you're right I made an
assumption what's what's the joke I made
an aside I did the thing same thing go I
did with the black doorman I assume that
all homeless people did drugs well it's
a pretty strong a ver I know the
evidence is on my favorite still I mean
there's probably a couple of them out
there that don't well the good news is
they're likely not listening to this
right
[Music]